ي من شبكه انفاق استثمرت فيها ملاين
الدولارات وشارك تزها نا المخربين هذا
المشروع قاده محمد السنوار
اخ اخ يحيى سنوار وهو اداره بشكل شخصي حتى
الان كشفنا اكثر من 4 كيلومترات من طول
النفق وهذا هو المشروع الاكبر بالنسبه
لحماس في داخل الانفاق وجدنا ادوات قتاليه
كثيره النفق لم يخترق حدود حدود اسرائيل
ولكنه وصل نقطه قرب معبر ايرز وهو الذي
اتاح الاف الفرص العامه لالاف
الفلسطينيين
وحماس
اختار السابع من اكتوبر ان يستهدف هذا
المعبر الذي مثل الامل بالنسبه للكثير من
الفلسطينيين هذا لم يكن نفقا عاديا بل كان
مدينه ارهابيه تحت الارض تحت
الارض مقامه بناء هذه الارض هذه الانفاق
مقابل ان يصرف الاموال على قطاع غزه وايضا
كانت هناك عمليات هجوميه في قطاع غزه قبل
عده
ايام تم القضاء على مخربين من من قبل جيش
الدفاع سنواصل ان نكشف بنى بنى حماس
الارهابيه من تحت الارض وايضا س نقتل
المخربين هناك ونقضي على هذه الانفاق
قواتنا تواصل القتال ضد حماس في شمالي
قطاع ز وفي جنوب قطاع غزه وفي كل مكان
يوجد فيه مخربون وايضا هناك
ايضا الامر
مطلوب
العمل جيش الدفاع مصمم على القضاء على
حماس وقواتنا تواصل العمل ببطوله وقوه في
كل انحاء قطاع غزه
وايضا فما يقول حماس عن المخطوفين يبين ان
حماس سيء جدا من يحصل على هذه الامور
للمساومه هذه منظمه ارهابيه مثل
حماس
لدينا الاخلاق ان نقوم بكل شيء من اجل
اعاده كل المخطوفين والمخطوف الى الوطن
سنواصل العمل بكل الجهود الاستخباريه
والعمليات وايضا جهود اخرى وبكل قوه من
اجل ان نحقق هذا اله
نشرنا اليوم
صور مبنى كان فيه المخطوفين الثلاثه 200
متر عندما عندما حدث الحادث
الماساوي نحن نفحص مبنى اخر يمكن ان يكون
فيه هؤلاء المخطوفين ونحن نواصل التحقيق
في هذا الهدف ونستخلص العبط رئيس الاركان
كان هناك اليوم مع القوات كذا على امور
تتعلق بالتحقيق الاولي قلوبنا وافكارنا مع
العائلات
الصعبه في
الشمال هجمنا عده اهداف لحزب الله في
لبنان مبنى عسكري ومبنى قتالي ومواقع
استخبارات وايضا هاجمنا خلايا ارهابيه في
جنوب لبنان ومنذ بدايه الحرب هاجمنا
وقضينا على اكثر من 120 خليه ارهابيه جنوب
لبنان اليوم هي منطقه قتاليه
وايضا سنواصل العمل ضد مواقع حزب الله
الذين
هاجمها ايضا ستكون هناك هجمات عندما يستمر
حزب الله في الوجود في هذه المنطقه اليوم
بعد ظهر اليوم مخرب قتل او
هاجم ضابط في رنتيس اي هذا الضابط هذا
لاحق المخرب واطلق النار وايضا قواتنا
تمكنت من القبض على المخرب ايضا وكنا هناك
في عمليات ضد الارهاب وايضا هاجمنا من
الجو قوات المخربين التي هاجمتنا
وبالاضافه لذلك اعتقلنا عده مطلوبين
ووجدنا اسلحه سنواصل العمل ضد الارهاب
يهودا والسامره وفي كل مكان وفي كل
الجبهات قوات جيش الدفاع مستعده وفي
الجبهه الداخليه
المزم بتوج الب الداخليه وايضا حماس هناك
القوه من اطلاق النار
ونحن نؤكد على هذه التوجيهات وبالاضافه
الى ذلك كان هناك
منشورات انه انه يمكن عوده السكان للعمل
او السكن في المناطق هذه الامور ليست
مقرره حتى الان حتى الان لم نقرر امرا في
هذا الشان ونحن سنبلغ بشكل رسمي الجمهور
عندما نتخذ قرارا ويجب الانتظار
بصبر ومن القيادات المواطنين
اسئله
[موسيقى]
شت ان انكم اكتشفت نفقا كبيرا في بالقرب
من مناطق اسرائيل ايضا هل هناك معلومات
استخباريه كيف كانت هذا هذا النفق عدد
كبير من السنوات وايضا ما هي الامكانيه ان
يكون هناك عده انفاق اخرى بهذا الكبر ونحن
لا نعرف عنها هذه هذا المشروع هذه المشروع
جزء او هذا النفق جزء من المشروع الذي قام
به حماس وايضا هناك هذا احد المواقع
وسنكشف المواقع او الانفاق الاخرى والتي
سنقوم بتدمير
نحن خلال هذه العمليه يسالنا لماذا ياخذ
وقت كبير في هذه الحرب اننا نعالج الانفاق
وفتحات الانفاق تحت الارض بالاضافه الى
قتل المخربين فوق الارض نقتلهم تحت الارض
وفي النهايه سنقضي عليهم وايضا في هذه
المناطق الاستراتيجيه في النفق وهذا ياخذ
وقتا فيما يتعلق بهذا النفق حماس اعدها
بشكل جيد للاختباء لقاده حماس مثل محمد
سنوار
وايضا سيتم التحقيق فيما فيما يتعلق مع
التحقيقات في الحرب ولكن الامر المهم هناك
مشروع كبير هذا النفق ومن اجل الوصول الى
معبر ايرز وتم استخدامها خلال الحرب وايضا
عندما تمت الهجوم استخدموا فيه وتم كشفه
وقتلنا فيه مخربين وسنواصل الكشف عن هذه
الانفاق و ونقضي على البناى
التحتيه السؤال الثاني هل هناك امكانيه عن
وجود مزيد مثل من مثل هذه الانفاق ونحن
نميز بين انفاق من هذا النوع وايضا هذه
البنى من هذه الامور ونحن نعالج هذه
الانفاق وايضا عندما
تقوم قوتنا بالكشف عن هذه الانفاق سنبلغ
الجمهور وهذا ما
نعالجه فيما يتعلق بالكشف هذا النفق هل
حسب تقديرات الاستخبارات هل مثل هذه
الانفاق موجوده في جنوبي قطاع غزه عند
محور فيلا
دلفي وهل حماس مستعد لتوجه الى
صفقه نحن
نبلغكم هناك لدينا فيه
المخربين وايضا سننشر المزيد من ذلك عندما
تتقدم قواتنا وهذا مرتبط بامن قواتنا ايضا
ونحن دائما نفحص
و نفحص في الميدان ولا نعتمد
على تاكيد كبير وفيما يتعلق في الانفاق في
منطقه رفح وما تعلق افاق الجديد فيما
يتعلق بقاده
حماس ومطالبهم بوقف اطلاق النار حتى تحقيق
هذه السف نقول اولا نحن نحارب حماس الذي
يجب تفكيكه وهذا الامر سيتواصل سنواصل
تفكيك حماس ونلاحق في شمال قطاع غزه وفي
كل مكان يجب ان تفهموا احد الاهداف
المركزيه هي اعاده المخطوفين عليه
كل الجهود الاستخباريه والعمليات
والمجهودات الاخرى التي تحدث معا مع
عملياتنا في الميدان من اجل ان نصل الى
النتيجه الافضل في اعاده المخطوفين